thrilled to have this guy call into the
show he's one of my favorite people on
the planet
and um and he's what what you had to say
last night chris webber on live
television was beautiful i texted you
right away
and i appreciate you joining me the next
day how are you sir i'm doing great
thanks for having me on rich
so what's going through your mind right
now chris
see what oh man well it's just uh just a
lot of emotion you know
um i think it was just reported that the
players have decided to play i'm not
sure if that's true
if you got that on your end and i'm just
i'm i'm just i don't know if happy is
the word
i'm i'm proud that young people
had had so much
passion and was it had so much pain
and so much love in their hearts that
it just didn't sit right with them and
they decided
to do something which meant do nothing
yesterday and
on the only point i was trying to well i
tried to make a few points but the point
i wanted to make about the players
yesterday was i just didn't want to bash
him
i just didn't want to everyone to throw
away what they did because it's funny
sometimes you'll be like all these
entitled athletes they never give back
and then if they
do uh take off a boycott oh they don't
know what it's really like so my thing
yesterday was
i just you know really happy that i'm
with turner and we have a platform to
talk they call me about 10 minutes
before
the show and says you want to come over
i run i'm sweating i put on my
suit and i just wanted to stand with
those players in some way and
and if they did in fact decide to play
i'm very happy
that they're going to continue because
they started the conversation i'm just
i'm just glad that they started they
continued however you want to put put
the conversation back in light and so
um it's a lot of emotion i've never been
we've never been through this
in sports before and so i'm encouraged
by seeing
the lions the other day stop practice
baseball
other people um you know i was
encouraged and hopefully
hopefully people can just express their
pain have conversation
and hopefully at least to change well i
then let's let's discuss this a little
bit more chris because i could already
see it coming
uh you can too uh the the the uh
the conversation um that
you're talking about needs to be had and
it's important to be had
um and then uh others pointing out that
uh without action
then um what does it all mean anyway
and the players were just virtue
signaling to begin with you know that's
coming
certainly if the if the stoppage only
lasts one
or two playoff days why is it so
important
to have the conversation chris man
because if if we don't have the
conversation you know
this is a tricky thing i don't even know
if i should go here but i i believe
personally
that because of sports
you know i believe personally those
sports is the first introduction
of someone not like you into your family
into your living room
i i suspect that in the 50s and 60s 40s
when jackie robinson came into baseball
that there were not many black people in
the homes
of white americans
there weren't people that you could say
hey son i want you to work hard like
jackie or
you know sports what sports does is take
all the blinders off and it just puts it
on the characteristics hard work tough
show up you know things that we all are
common denominators of life they
call it meyer and the fact that my
nephew loves
johnson as much as he loves lebron
speaks to that
and everyone keeps saying you know well
or
they're going to be people say well they
didn't get anything accomplished or they
didn't do anything and
that's why i wanted to encourage the
players because that's the trick back
the trick back is
hey guys go back and plan something and
then take action
so then what you're gonna have is 400
players
400 agents uh 400 nothing will get done
that way
this had to be an impulse it had to be
something that
everything wasn't planned out right to
do because it can't
be planned out right they're gonna be
issues they're gonna be
situations and so for me the
black kids the white kids that called me
yesterday were excited about
change we're excited about something
were they missing basketball
yes but the youth gets it in my opinion
the youth gets it and they understand
that it's it's bigger than just the game
and so
i i do hope that guys play that's just
hope there's a message i hope that
there's change but i was just inspired
by
the impulse sometimes you just got to
say screw it
you know and let the chips fall where
they may that's exact
you know maybe it's that's the reason
why we both chose the uh
great institution of higher learning
that we did that's exactly what i said i
i got the sense from hearing what i
heard
from the bubble what i heard people say
from the bubble
that the sense was screw it we are not
up for entertaining
a country where we feel there's a large
population that will not
entertain our humanity literally
that's what i got the sense of and the
fact is that yesterday
my nine-year-old walked up to me and
said are we watching rockets
and thunder and i said no and he said
why
and i told him why and a conversation
started in my household
that happened yesterday chris and it
wouldn't have maybe oh
it had the rockets and the thunder not
played um
or had they played basketball i mean we
we do talk about the real world with our
kids a lot
but sports brought that on chris that
happened yesterday
in my household yeah and and it's it's
messed up because he's a nine-year-old
and maybe you shouldn't have to have
that talk you know
it's messed up but that's just the way
that it is and
and because you had that talk he's going
to be a better individual
whatever the talk was because i know it
i know
that talk had compassion and empathy and
that's all you want
i mean that's it's just it's just that
simple man it's just compassionate
empathy
that's all no one wants to be favored or
the other or
it's just compassionate empathy a man
was shot seven times in the back in
front of his three
children you know if you if you really
want to look
i mean when i was 16 i remember it was a
song by chub rock
and um he was talking about yusef
hawkins getting killed
i mean like so when you talk about the
trauma and god's being traumatized and
where these players come from
in the neighborhoods they come from they
go back i i've said it before
and the league is great um the league
has been very supportive
but i know more athletes that have given
more to charity than that team
has during their time there these these
are guys that really
you know it's just things survivable's
remorse you know i know that i was given
opportunities that other people weren't
given
you know because i could play basketball
because of my height and all those
things and that's how the world is
sometimes
but it's messed up when it is a whole
community and you're the only one
or you're looked at like oh you're on
the rich heisman rich eisen show
hey you're not going through what they
go through why are you worried about it
you know it's those type of things and i
just hope that whatever
whether you're extra conservative
whether you're left right it doesn't
really matter i just hope that within
this moment
you see it for what it is and it is the
pain of the players
it is empathy it is sympathy it is
questioning
why it it really is i mean we've seen it
all over
all over the world and i think social
media has been a big part of because
guys now can go to their own platform i
mean
think about it i think doc rivers really
set the set it off
but this speech after the game the other
night that we had
and so um i just hope people just see
that these are human beings and
individuals as
athletes and i would hope that they
would say
wow their parents raised them right not
to just when you made basketball forget
it when you make it to the league forget
everybody else and go live
uh in your mansion on the mountain
that's not what these guys are doing
a few more minutes left with chris
webber here on the rich eisen show can
you give voice to how the bubble is
affecting
some of this the fact is again that the
players and because we had kenny the jet
smith on yesterday
who brought this up about uh this
subject
um and we all know that he d-miked on
live television last night
um inside the nba studio
um and said that you know he just didn't
feel
like he didn't feel like it and that he
was doing that in solidarity with
players
but anyway he he mentioned that the
bubble adding the fact that you are
there that
the players don't can't be
[Music]
about it sitting in the bubble and so
how is that affecting everything do you
think chris yeah
i think i think we need to let's
so we'll get to that bubble but you know
the bubble we're in now where you can't
hug your friend you can't see your
grandmother
i really think that everything has to be
a perfect storm
and this was the perfect storm for
activism
because there's no distractions there
weren't there aren't the sports it's not
the college football ramping up all the
other things that
that i like they are but then it hasn't
been on tv and so
i think the world has gotten a chance to
see what really goes on
and watch the news probably way too much
and see these same incidents happen
and i think here in the bubble it um
so i've been here about two weeks now
and it's weird it's different i've never
been away from my kids this long
uh so you're dealing with different
emotions um
and for these guys i think the bubble
affected them that
they're in their rooms i mean you play
golf you can
maybe walk around outside but you can't
leave the the campus of the hotel
and i think a lot of these guys feel
like
i'm i'm not using the value that i have
that i'm wasting my value that i could
be doing something and they
and they may feel like it's frustrating
that i'm here and not doing anything
while the world is burning
you know um and so i do think the bubble
has had an effect
on guys and their anxiousness and and
they're wanting to speak out and wanting
to do something but
i sense that from everybody from
everybody people just
going to work are tired people you know
you know
kids can't go to school i just think the
frustration and seeing what it is people
are just calling for peace
that's all it is people just want peace
in the midst of all this storm and i
think that
being in a bubble has let guys really
sit and focus on it for hours at a time
and um and they just want to do
something about it
all right chris so before i let you go
what do you think happens next here do
you think uh
because if if there is no if you will
announcement of something tangible
by that i mean players and owners in the
league got together
and something is being funded or
something is being
created to address the issue
that caused the players to strike i mean
i know
you could say boycott strike is really
was what withholding services boycott is
withholding money
to buy something so um
if if there isn't that we already kind
of hit the fact that there will be
criticism of really what's all this for
except the conversation and we've
already just established
that conversation does have immense
value
but what do you think the next the next
step is here
when games resume there has to be
uh action dr phil said there got to be
some verbs in those sentences
but i would say this i would tell the
players
don't rush because of the pressure i
would say even if you come back and play
tonight
you don't have to have a full-out
platform
today because that takes time you need
to bring in
researchers you need to bring in experts
you need to bring in notes from those
communities so
my thing is the conversation started it
and the conversation
that you have with your nine-year-old
son that means he's gonna have it with
his nine-year-old son and i don't mean
that conversation i mean where he talks
to his kid about the world
and inclusive in conversation so number
one they've won that war
just just putting it out there and
second i think that
you're gonna have to have some actions
what will that be i'm not sure
but i do believe that each team will
probably get with their local government
each team you know you talk about the
services and the money
and the taxes that these teams pay into
these cities
maybe it is something where you can
direct the taxes maybe it is something
where
you can bring changing initiatives i i
can't speak for the players
i know that they've inspired me and i'll
be back on your show
in a couple months to tell you what i'm
doing so i'm
doing stuff and they encouraged me to
continue to do it and
i don't know what their plans are but i
tell you this
there are a lot of people with plans
individually collectively
and um i'm happy that they sparked
rekindled reignited aflame and a lot of
people
and i don't want them to hurry up and
just put anything together because that
it doesn't matter black lives matter on
the court all that stuff really doesn't
matter if we don't do action
i just hope they take their time with
the sense of urgency that they have
and if they announce something the
beginning of next season we can all wait
till then
as long as it's robust as long as it's
hard-hitting as long as it's going to
make change
i just want them to make sure that they
have the best plan possible
and however long that takes that's how
long it's going to take don't be
pressured by that but just make sure at
the end of the day
you complete what you started that's all
i just hope they complete what they
started
uh at some time i love you chris webber
love you man
um love you too are you love your wife
morgan i know that
that's fun although it's appreciated
uh are you facetiming with those babies
is that basically oh yeah
yeah facetiming facetiming every day man
so yeah everything and we're potty
trainers so i'm facetiming a lot just
looking at the ceiling while they're
sitting on the potty singing hold on a
second
so is this i know we're doing everything
virtually and by zoom these days are you
zoom potty training is that literally
what you just said well
no i'm i'm just i'm zoomed babysitting
so my wife will say
hey sit on the toilet and talk to your
dad
that is amazing that is fantastic all
right chris you take care of yourself
you be well
thank you guys guys be safe that's the
only